second start for lizardo against the san
francisco giants he's got the good
slider he's got the good change up good
fastball he's got the pitches to make it
work couple of ground outs for lizardo
to open up the ball game
let's hit in the hole marcus backhand
straightens up his throat is just in
time and three ground ball out the
inning is over and lizardo works at one
two three top of the first and three
ground balls on the hill today for the
giants will be the veteran kevin gausman
gosman 29 years of age he's in his
seventh year at the big league level so
here's la stella hitting 287
got him nice win by gosman we're gonna
get shot with us you guys seem to really
have a good time yeah i mean
honestly why not you know i can't really
like i'm always one to celebrate with
the boys
nasty um
i feel like each week we're we're doing
something different
it's just a lot of fun like cheering on
the air yeah
and now here's austin slater change up
strike three caught on the inside corner
it's four k's now through three innings
for lizardo and we are scoreless no
score two on two out on a fly ball to
centers first time he's over four in the
series
slowly hit simeon charges he's got it
juggles the throw to first is not in
time solano gets caught off third and
he's out
wonderful donovan solano rounded third
he had no place to go
he got caught and the a's drew behind
him how about this play talk about
alertness
on both ends matt olsen but also how
about jake lamb just joining the ball
club and being alert enough to catch
this ball coming back across the diamond
from matt olsen and getting a huge out
so the two out walk to cannon and
that'll bring up matt olson
there's a base hit center field this
should give the a's the lead canna
hustles around third he comes in to
score
so a two out walk in the a's take
advantage so olson gets the first hit
off gazman and it's an rbi base hit
pitch down and away just goes with it
they're shifting him to hit the ball to
the right side and matt olsen
big three-run home run last night look
at the hole the big gap right there
and boy heads up base running by mark
kenneth gets himself in scoring position
otherwise you have to get back to back
two out hits unnecessary 42 runs batted
in big battles
one nothing in favor of the a's and
that'll bring up longoria he was struck
out and singled out feels straight up
and the pitch to longoria bounced to
third right to lamb he's got it flipped
his second in time and a good job by
lizardo today
six innings and five hits and no runs he
is half the lead we go to the bottom of
the six it's one nothing a's now three
and oh la stella
and this tie so a four pitch walk
kissimmee to fly ball to right and the
strikeout so far
oh yes takes the pass well guzman they
just threw three pitches in the exact
same spot to mark the simian all up and
in and
out of the strike zone which is kind of
strange yeah had good control the whole
day it's been excellent all day six
strikeouts easy strikeouts mark khanna
right-handed hitter has scored the only
run of the game after he walked with two
out in the fourth inning
now he swings ground ball to short and
robertson dropping to his knees to get
it over the second one solano back to
first to a double play
beautifully started that ball was just
annihilated by kanna
and
on to the seventh now jesus lazaro six
solid innings as we talked about in the
beginning of our telecast the importance
of lizardo pitching deep in the game
six great innings of pitching and did a
great job spotting the slider the
changeup outside good fastball took
something off the pitches and waiting on
a sunny day
so second hit for the ends and here's
lamb
it to right field
the saudis back and
that baby's gone insurance runs for the
a's three nothing
well it was just a matter of time
and here it is again jake lamb
puts a great swing on a little slider
down and in all aboard
next stop
pound town so a huge a couple of runs
here in the bottom of the seventh
did pretty well the center dubon going
back dubon near the wall and he missed
it
one run scores
two runs score la stella the third he's
got a triple and it's five to nothing so
le stella hit that ball well dubon
miss played it a little bit and la
stella will take it
[Applause]
and turn around there and then jump and
no reason to jump didn't have to
approach the warning track and jumped
and you know but just a little bit
inexperienced in playing center field
and it cost him a couple of runs so la
stella give him a couple of rbis
and the a's have scored four times here
in the bottom of the seventh
more adventure for darren ruff he's got
a long run and he dropped it la stella
comes in to score marcus to second and
it's six to nothing
and the defensive wheels have completely
fallen off
for the giants
talk about a long run look where he's
playing down the left field line he runs
and runs forever
and then tries to backhand as he slid
and missed it
he was praying please be in foul
territory but it wasn't
so it's a five-run inning
trevino comes in he is pitcher number
four and here's the pitch to him and
that's swinging on a fly ball left field
grossman going back under it now waiting
for it he's there and he makes the catch
and these have beaten the giants in
back-to-back games by the score of six
nothing and now the magic number to
clinch the division is down to one and
these will await the outcome of the
diamondbacks and the astros later in
houston
and if the d-backs win that game the a's
will
clinch the american league west for the
first time since 2013.
[Applause]